today we are playing among us with
memeulous courage
wildcat infinite and loser fruit tons of
big names
i'm excited to kill you guys and i
haven't told anybody in the lobby this
yet but whoever is alive at the end of
the game gets ten
thousand 000 each
now i'm really excited to kill you guys
let's go
fire up the game let's get right into it
if you kill me and your imposter i'm
gonna hate you forever
my heart's going oh good ten thousand
dollars down the line good luck
everybody
bruh i have never played this map what
is this map
i'm horrible at being the imposter i
gotta get away from everybody
who do i trust oh we're on the big map
too god
i have never needed to stay alive more
in a video game in my entire life
10 000 us dollars no australian dollars
real
real dollars okay i i have no idea what
i'm doing i've
i've never done this map oh my god i
don't want to die there's ten thousand
oh don't kill me loser fruit please all
right we're staying together we're
staying together here
oh my god look at us all here i am
terrified
no i need to get near somebody i gotta
do a task checking
anyone dead no nobody's dead i don't
know can i trust me milas
i don't know oh my god my hands are so
sweaty
just checking in make sure everyone's
alive everyone's still eligible for the
money
i thought i died i just want to remind
you all 10 000
is on the line per person so imposters
if you could do me a favor and start
killing some people
that would be nice don't kill me if we
just randomly killed the two imposters
right now
i'd be out 70 grand two everyone shoot
a little bit oh somebody saw something
you have a k in front of your name vote
them out
all right i'm down to vote carl wait are
you actually chris please don't
yeah wait are you guys skipping overton
you guys will lose if you vote wait wait
wait also if we finish our task we all
get money hey
imposter start killing some people
everybody stick together do tests two
people voted carl
jimmy and mimulus puts us on them oh my
gosh imagine
voting out the wrong person and taking
10 grand away from them
i'm too scared to do anything on this
map because i have no idea where
anything is i don't even know where the
tasks are
but like don't but like don't you know
oh
no oh no lights
chandler stick near me blue don't you
kill me don't you do it i trust you blue
no
it was blue blue rose blue it was blue
rose
what are you kidding me jailer i watched
chandler killed courage i watched him
kill courage i
saw it happen bro i literally just
walked up there car you kidding me chris
what are you doing
i saw you do keys at the beginning so i
know you're confirmed and i don't want
to die cause 10 grand
10 grand is on the line you're chasing
me down like a lion in a gazelle dude
it's chandler for sure we're voting
chandler let's use this time oh my god i
swear to god carl
i don't know you walked out of security
and then like five seconds later said
that so you might have just killed
someone and reported the body
this kill is 100 not chris okay but i'm
talking about fruity there are two kills
guys
yeah this was a double kill or like wild
and chris were you guys together the
whole time
not the whole time but since lights yeah
since lights i promise you it is
chandler i don't know how much more i
can prove it let's see
oh my god i'm voting chandler i've
always loved literally i didn't even see
the body
i ran up there and it got reported so
someone hit the button and let's vote
carl out next
we're sure no stop stop don't vote me if
the game ended now i would have to pay
out 60 grand
imposters kill more people oh i'm not
i'm not going left reactor there's no
way i'm ever going
all right i kind of trust carl dude i
feel bad for anyone who dies that's so
much money on the line oh mimi let's get
the heck
jimmy wasn't pressing it
i thought jimmy was about to kill me um
i'm gonna say jimmy wasn't pressing
buttons
i literally was the one that did it i
went to go do top right reactor and i
saw carl go up there and then i went
left to go left the reactor and somebody
else did it carl just threw me out there
you watched me do the test you didn't do
it so
i just walked up and clicked it and it
automatically went blue
guys i can tell you right now it's carl
because i didn't know stop
why would i have proof in chandler do we
vote carl just to be safe
no no i don't know as the guy with 60
000
currently on the line here i'm telling
you it is carl
if we vote jimmy we all get 10k i'm not
imposter there is a world where it isn't
jimmy okay
it's not you literally just watched me
uh we've got 15 seconds skip here skip
here skip here skip here skip here skip
here oh god carl might be big big brain
playing no
i took the task he's taking credit for
my task
i think it is coral i think it's coral
bro my heart is in my mouth i have no
idea what i'm doing
all right i did it again and they saw it
where's the emergency meeting the minute
anybody comes up to me i'm gonna
instantly press the button because
10 grand is on the line oh god
somebody's coming in here i'm so scared
all right here we go let's jimmy you
scared me standing by the button carl
yeah exactly and you were trying to take
credit for me doing it last round vote
carl
he has no defense now listen even an
imposter can do it you know that right
jimmy
i did not know that all right i'm
unvoting carl
oh no oh no dang it that way
i've never been more confused in my life
i think carl's safe
i think it's carl but i don't have
enough actually i still think it's coke
because even if an apostate can do it
why is he trying to take credit together
carl wanted to get out chandler and the
fact that nobody has died since voting
him out makes you think there's only one
imposter left and carl was right
skip it's not me i could believe it's
jimmy i could believe it's
george bro i'm not it let's do no one's
ever alone
i feel like it's carl but i don't
actually know if it's carl yeah i think
i've i've lost 10 grand here i
don't know what to do i'm too scared to
kill anyone there's three people
not talking and they're getting away
with murder
should i just do a stat kill should i
just send it
dude i don't like the way mr these is
just following us around dude
i'm not trying to kill you all cat i'm
not i swear guys tasks are almost done
if we can do
tasks then we'll freaking win i don't
know what to do
all right let's start off i have an
opportunity
i knew it was memeulous
there we go he did the kill oh what a
kill
all right okay i did it i i i i fought
my fear
why aren't lights turning on oh oh my
god
okay kayla's where are you right by the
uh the vitals
this is either kayla's or mimulus this
kill is never carl or mr beast or myself
i was doing the um
oil thing me and wild are the only two
that are proof in 100
right now i actually trust mr beast now
even though we were all together and i
was terrified the entire time the fact
that he didn't kill any of this i kind
of trust
my gut is telling me george let's let's
vote mimulus well it wasn't always me
it's nothing personal i just care about
money more than your life right now
that's all it is
stop stop stop i say we i say we skip no
carl
i'm not convinced it's not jimmy i was
stuck in the double doors
it's one of three people in my eyes and
i have no evidence to believe it's one
or the other
i'm skipping it it's memeulous i'm
telling you if you want to throw
it don't vote memeulous i've done
nothing sauce jenny
skip if you're not imposter skip if
you're not imposter i don't know what to
do
you guys are throwing jimmy i don't
disagree that it could be memeulous
let's prove it
wildcat and jimmy sit with me the entire
time and do tasks i haven't gotten mine
done follow me okay i don't wanna sweat
off tasks that's a lot of money
i'm not doing tests i'm gonna just
follow around carl come with me please
carl come with me please channel all
right i appreciate you uh
you destroying the lights this is so
high pressure dude
this is so scary carl come on man we got
this but i am
so bad at this game they're all clumped
together man
how i can't do this if you leave me we
lose you're throwing if you leave me
he's not going to get one of them alone
he's going to have to stay femulus
it's time turn off the lights stack kill
the lights i think it's me melissa
because
where is he put it to waste oh okay it's
up there
all right okay oh me melis emily's came
in late where the heck was he
i'm so scared they're all together stop
it
oh no not the lights again stop oh
spooky spooky spooky okay me and wildcat
are 100 proven now
he's gonna see that i'm he's waiting on
me so now we're both proven 100
we can win by tasks guys
okay all right all right i sent it i
sent it
it was him i said it was him
why does no one believe me oh brown's
dead
has to be meamulous oh i found the body
thank god
oh no it had to have been nemu this then
right well it was all together it wasn't
me
i was with you guys right as me and carl
left jimmy it happened so caleb what
were you doing what did you do kind of
just following everyone around because
i've been done with tasks
okay who has tasks then i honestly
haven't played this map before i've got
one in
uh i think it's the lab guys it has to
be memeous here right we don't vote we
don't vote actually if
we don't vote first of all second of all
i'm gonna put more sauce on infinite how
can i prove myself to you guys come on
just stay away from us that's how stay
away from us and if you die we'll know
stay away this is intense oh my
goodness bro i'm not gonna lie it's a
miracle
i'm scared so one of them's gonna die
and gonna be really pissed off that they
played the whole game and died at the
end
yeah oh they're so close together okay
mimulus don't freaking go into cams if
you try if he goes and you're
running oh my god this is so close this
is so close
what what is mimia's thinking oh man i
need to isolate him somehow
what is he even trying to do does he
even have a strategy
i don't want to do i'm gonna cry
no ten thousand dollars gone like that
oh yep it's mimi is okay it's ah
uh uh we lose here we just lost because
wildcat ran away
oh it's me melissa i saw him killing
cams yeah it's meaningless it's memeless
it's mimi
i know for a fact it's mimi bro i just
fall apart i didn't see anything
do you want to win oh let's go
right in fairness this is like my second
time playing this map
i think i deserve an a for effort
bayless
why don't you press the button just lose
10 grand
congratulations carl and infinite on
each winning ten
thousand dollars we almost won
i hate you i love you